good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Thursday hope
everyone's having an amazing day thus
far I am because I'm here with my girl
hey Jax how you doing I'm doing good
thank you so much for asking I had such
a horrible migraine all day yesterday
and in my sleep like it was so bad I
couldn't at towards the end of the night
like I couldn't even see but I couldn't
look at my phone I couldn't do anything
it was really bad so I'm just feeling
really grateful for today and for Clear
head yesterday the migraine like started
at the beginning of the show so you
could like whenever here's my tell if
I'm ever like touching my head like this
on the show it means that I have a
migraine so it was it was starting
yesterday it just snowballed all day and
by the time I got into bed like I was
just seriously not okay so I'm just
feeling grateful for a new day and a
fresh start there's something about the
new lease on life you get after being
sick that really can like change the
perspective of your whole life life like
because you feel like you're in such a
low and like there's no hope for the
future and then one day you wake up
whether whatever your illness is like
then you wake up feeling better and it's
like you're seeing life through through
different eyes no it's like yesterday I
had so many things that I needed to do
but I couldn't do any of them because I
wasn't up to the task and so today it's
like well I'm going to do all of these
things because I am able to do them no
and today definitely for for us at least
is a little bit of a Friday energy
because it is our last show of the week
There's no show tomorrow since I'm going
to be in Delaware I have a show tonight
that I'll be heading to right after we
record this episode so today is like a
really busy Friday
yeah also I was having this funny
thought I went to dinner with some
friends last night and I was saying how
I feel like moms who have migraines in
like books and movies they're always
like the mom who's always in like the
room in bed with my commercials like no
but the commercials always have the mom
who's like fighting through her migraine
and like playing with the kids even when
she like shouldn't but I feel like in
every book that I read it's like oh my
mother has migraines so she's just like
down for the count but how like I can't
choose whether or not I have migraines
so like if I have migraines and I need
to like lay in the dark in my room then
I'm like a cliche mother who has
migraines well I think in like books and
movies a lot of times like migraines are
like what kids think parents have when
the parents like a deadbeat or an
alcoholic or like hungover right maybe
they have so many migraines like my
hangovers are migraines and my migraines
are hangovers but maybe the volume is
because they're always hungover no it's
like you know it's like such a cliche
like Mom can't drive into school today
she has a migraine but it's like yeah or
like the kids
the kids playing by themself in the
front yard and like some random person
comes over like where's your mommy is a
migraine no totally it's like a
euphemism for like a bigger thing like a
kid can't understand yet but what if you
are a mom that actually has migraines no
these deadbeat mothers are out here like
making it hard for the mothers with
migraines yeah so I just always think
about that like I don't want to be like
the mom with migraines but I am a mother
with migraines and yes I do need to lay
in the dark and I need peace and quiet
no like the Excedrin commercial that
like ran throughout our childhood like
really is ringing true right now it's
like that Mom who like needs to do it
all but she can't because she has a
migraine and Excedrin is here to help
yeah I guess I don't try Excedrin enough
I'm gonna get some I get migraines too
but like a few years ago I went through
like a really bad bout and migrant
Excedrin Extra Strength it has a little
caffeine in it too so it gives you like
a little pep in your step you can't take
it before bed you have to take it in the
morning it's actually a stunning drug
yeah I do have the magic pills but I
think I've said like they work best if I
take them right before I'm about to go
to sleep so I don't take them during the
day because they might just like not
work and they don't prescribe very many
so I can't just have one that's not
going to work there are a couple drugs
out there not to get into big Pharma
again but there are a couple drugs out
there that are actual like Miracle drugs
like Zofran or your migraine pills that
like you have to beg for a pack of four
like why why why are you making us
suffer no and then also then I get
anxiety like I took my last magic pill
and so now it's like if my headache
didn't go away today like I have nothing
I don't know if I've ever told this
story but you know Ben has always had
migraines and he has a prescription for
those migraine medicine magical pills do
you see the same one as me the same I'm
not sure but one time like when we were
dating in college I had such a bad
migraine and he gave me one and I was
going to bed and it brought on the worst
panic attack of my [ __ ] life
absolutely literally it's so me I'm
always having problems you just can't
like accept the miracle for what it is
something nefarious no I have to make it
a story one of my favorite its stories
you have to make it about you 100 and
speaking of making stories
yesterday Jackie and I recorded an
episode for patreon it's available now
it's a podcast episode
um and it's really centered around
something that's been a really hot
button issue here at the Toasties last
couple of weeks and over the last few
years honestly
um it was a detailed recap a dive in to
my favorite stories we're always talking
about like stories I cannot stop
repeating Dennis's funeral Law and Order
episodes and I think a lot of people
unless you've been listening to every
single episode from the beginning and
you have an amazing memory a lot of
people don't even know what these
stories are like what their importance
to me is
um so we did about an hour-long podcast
episode where I really dive into not
only what happened to the story what
meaningful lessons I learned and why I
bring them up on the podcast because
they do not all of them some of them do
spark an interesting intellectual debate
yeah so it was pretty well-rounded
Claudia talks about obviously the story
she's in some she's providing detail in
color like she never has before like
Leonardo DiCaprio like I've never given
her the platform to do before
and also she's talking about like what
like when she brings it up like what
she's trying to say what's the larger
message and what she wants us to take
away from it
it was for me it was a really cathartic
episode maybe I'll stop talking about
those stories now because I feel like
I'm finally like said my piece it's all
out there and now we've now we said it
exactly so that was a really fun episode
I cannot believe that today is December
that just hit me like a ton of bricks
it's December 1st
Have a Holly Jolly Christmas it's the
best time of the year it really is it
really really is let me ask you a
question
your first December where it's most
likely not going to be a white Christmas
how does that make you feel is December
hitting different in the tropics
maybe maybe that's why it's even like
more shocking that it's December but I
am coming to New York next week so that
I can experience
um the holiday joy and yeah I guess it's
weird that I'm wearing like a squirt
today but it's December but I was coming
home from dinner last night and I was I
was chilly oh I was so cute chill in the
air I was a chill so like it's cold here
so speaking of programming update Jackie
will be back in the New York Studio your
two girls will be back Back in the New
York Studio yeah five episodes next week
video and audio of your girlies getting
together being best friends sisters and
lovers yes and also programming update
because next week I'm recording the new
episode of the redheads with the girls
in person in studio so excited to be
together even though we always even when
it's supposed to come out today it was
supposed to come out today but it's
coming out next week the second Thursday
instead of the first Thursday also like
it being December when it's like our
episodes come out on the first Thursday
of the month but being on the first is
just a wild proposition but we would
have done it obviously but then I
realized in a few days I will be in New
York so if we push it we can record
together this episode is always longer
because we do argue and review so we
obviously recap the book we're reading
Horus by Geraldine Brooks I think it's
going to be like amazing I started it
it's so well written it's like that book
it's a Dana's Choice obviously always
her December pick is tops uh so we recap
the book and do everything along with
that talk about other books we've read
this month but then we also rate what
were the best three books each of us
read this year separately and then what
were the best three redheads books of
the year and the thing about the
redheads this year it was like we had
some really high highs and really low
lows there weren't a lot of like
mid-tier books so it's actually going to
be hard to choose the top three because
there's probably like top six
so we'll see
but you know what I'm glad you brought
that up because like the fact that like
the first Thursday of the month isn't
always the fourth like it's really
bothersome it's really confusing it's so
unnecessary like why there's months with
30 31 28 like I get it I get it but like
why
it's confusing and then also what's
really confusing is like when Monday is
the second it's like one day off and
then like so you expect that week is
going to be like first second third and
it's like everything is just off kilter
I just think it's it's genuinely
unnecessary
I would agree
let me tell you how I went to the next
game last night I haven't been to a
Knicks game in Forever it's the energy
and it was eclectic no except electric
um and I did the funniest thing like one
thing about me is when it comes to Ben
like I have to lie like I'm always
making stuff up just like see if I can
get him to believe it for years and he's
like always believing me like what's
wrong with you like a perfect example is
like for no reason I'll just make stuff
up I I remember like during the dirty
jeans tour I went to Arizona and on my
way home I remember
um I was sitting with a bunch of guys
and they were all talking they were on a
golf trip and that's when I I think I
realized for the first time like
Scottsdale and is like a golf
destination so when I got home I'm like
I'm packing I'm like oh my God Ben I
forgot to tell you like do you know what
was seated next to on the plane
he's like who I'm like this like pro
golfer everyone was freaking out I think
his name was like Roy or like Rory and
Ben was like Rory McIlroy I'm like yes
like he was so nice
and Ben was like no way he's like such a
big deal I'm like really he was like
such a regular guy like sitting next to
me like not flying commercial
and Ben was like and I was sitting in
first class which made it like a little
more believable even though Rory McIlroy
is like literally a billionaire like he
would never fly commercial
I'm like yeah it was so cool like he was
telling me like he was on some golf trip
with his buddies and Ben like believed
me I let it go on for like a few minutes
before I eventually tell him I'm lying
because I'm not like an actual liar
so last night I like like these lies
like they just come to me and they when
I tell you they're for no [ __ ] reason
okay so last night we're watching a game
and there's a player number 30 and like
he looks familiar to me because he's
like a popular Nick right now
so I'm like Ben who's number 30 like he
looks so familiar and he's like that's
Julius Randle I'm like I met him
I'm like I have his phone number he's
like what I'm like oh my God yes he like
told me he was a basketball player but I
thought he was just like you know
like plays on the weekends he said where
did you meet him and like I really
actually could not think of a good life
like where I would [ __ ] you're a bond
no but like that's not believable like
so I said
I said because on my time hop for that
day I was at the Luke Combs concert
actually a year ago yesterday I'm like
when I went to the Luke Combs concert
like we went backstage and there was
like this room for like VIPs which is
true
um and I met this guy and we were
talking and he like loves podcasts he
like listens to so many podcasts so we
like got my number he had so many
questions like I was literally making up
the most elaborate lie it's psychotic
and I was like I took his number I
literally thought he was like a nobody I
never even used a number I've had his
number on my phone for a year he's like
you're kidding me show me his number
now I wish I thought of the lie no like
no that's in the bathroom that's crazy
if you had if you went to those lengths
because then I would have put like
in my phone like Julius from Luke Combs
concert so it would have been believable
but then I started I was like wait I
don't think I remembered his name so
like I started looking up like
basketball player like Luke Combs and
then I got caught in my lie but he was
like living for it until that moment he
was like you've had Julius randle's
number for a year because of course
Ben's mind is like he could have
invested in Spritz like that said's
always thinking how can this work to my
advantage no of course and like Ben
being Ben all he needs is the phone
number from his wife's contact book and
then Julius Randle would be an investor
and a dream yeah
so that's just a little like does anyone
else like randomly just lie to their
partner like for literally no reason
about the most random like
inconsequential [ __ ] sometimes I like
[ __ ] around with Zach like if I talk to
you no you did that literally when I was
at your house about that meal delivery
app oh my God yes and obviously he like
was barely listening so I never got a
chance to be like gotcha and so I'm sure
he in some recess of his brain like
still thinks that that's a meal delivery
at so when I came down to Florida when
Olivia had given birth um a bunch of
Olivia's friends had started this meal
train which was so thoughtful it was
like this website everybody filled out
like a date that they were gonna bring
lunch dinner for like two weeks it was
literally first of all if one of your
friends has a baby it is the most
thoughtful gift like nobody has time to
cook and so every day these like hordes
of huge kosher home-cooked meals were
showing up
and we sat down for dinner of course we
were eating it even though it wasn't for
us they were dropping off so much food
yeah no it was for everyone and like
someone was like is this from the meal
train is this from meal train and we
were like yeah and I was exactly like
there's this new app called the real
train and they just it's like home to
cook meals that you can order and they
bring them and they could be kosher yeah
to your house and he was like cool and
like he never he like didn't really care
so I never was like gotcha so I'm sure
like one night soon he's gonna be like
should we try that out meal train should
we order meal train it's a good idea for
a nap it is and it was a great lie even
though like it's also a great way to get
poisoned by a stranger but I guess no
it's like it's not that good of an idea
when you actually go to build it but
like it's funny like a homemade food
delivery like people could you know have
a side hustle being chefs from their
kitchen and people would order that who
want homemade food and who don't want
like restaurants sweaty takeout sweaty
takeout
so yeah I guess we have that in common
we do I do that all the time and I do
some good ones too no it's like the more
you do it it's like so fun you're like
how can I be so diabolical and creative
today yeah I like took his car out and I
was gonna be like I I dented it but then
I was honestly too exhausted like I was
like making a face and he was like what
I was like forget it okay
I'm not in the mood to [ __ ] with you
lies are supposed to be harmless like
that's like a little mean no but it's
not like I went and dented his car so
that I could tell him like I just was
gonna make him like be like oh so he
went to the go look at it and then I
would be like kidding yeah eating but
also your husband does like dumb jokes
like that too all the time like he'll
walk into a room with his air pods in
and pretend to be on a call so you'll
ignore him because no that's not what he
does he'll be wearing his air pods and
talking to you he just happens to have
his airpods in and then he goes to take
out his air pods and says sorry what
were you saying I was on a call as if
every the whole conversation you just
had with him he was having with someone
else he's literally gaslighting us
that's his favorite thing I'm just like
it's the dumbest joke you have to tell
him to stop you you would think that I I
can you think I can
oh my God LOL well before we keep uh
chatting away let me tell you that
today's episode is sponsored by IHG
hotels and resorts the hotel company
that's made up of over 6 000 hotels and
amazing and 17 amazing Brands their
brands include Kimpton Hotels and
restaurants InterContinental Hotels and
Resorts Holiday Inn Express six senses
and more and they're taking their care
of their guests this holiday season at
aichi hotels and resorts with exclusive
benefits like member discounts a bonus
points offer when you download the new
ihg-1 rewards mobile app catalog savings
on travel gear and more so ihg's all-new
loyalty program ihg-1 rewards is making
it so much easier to check out and
redeem these can't miss offers right in
the palm of your hand with their new
mobile app if you download the new
mobile app if you haven't already you
can start earning points with ease and
redeem them for the things that you want
most you have to be a member so don't
wait to sign up like a resolution
actually really good resolution is like
to start getting your points and loyalty
programs on point and IHG is so great
because they have so many Brands so you
can stay at like a bunch of different
hotels and earn points for the same
loyalty program and then redeem them
however you want and also the app like
makes it really fun and easy to earn
points in different ways they're really
passionate about the belief that when
people are taken care of they feel free
to be themselves and live their best
lives so all you have to do is show up
guest in whatever way that works for you
and IG will take care of the rest so
through the mobile app you can find the
best rates book a room in seconds sort
results easily to find the information
that you need enjoy exclusive benefits
for ihg-1 rewards members and manage all
of your stays in one place for more
details on how to maximize your travels
this holiday season with IHG hotels and
resorts cyber offerings you can follow
at ihg1rewards on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter or visit ihg.com
cyber sale today's episode is also
sponsored by verst skin is complicated
but skin care should not be and that's
where verse comes in with their clean
results driven products at drugstore
prices from ethically sourced
ingredients to recycled packaging verst
products are developed for you with you
and with our planet in mind I am very
excited about verse being a sponsor be
because I found out about first at our
Spritz brunch there was an influencer
there who like really um I think her
name was kemi she was really into
skincare and I was like you have the
most amazing skin like what do you use
especially to take off makeup and she
recommended the first eucalyptus makeup
bomb and I've been using it ever since
and now I got more products since they
started
um working on the show with us it is the
best way to take off your makeup like it
actually gets rid of your makeup which
is just revolutionary I wear waterproof
mascara which can be really tough to get
off like I'm constantly pulling clumps
out of my eyes but the verse bomb is
really tough on waterproof mascara it's
fabulous they have a bunch of great
products at first and they use the high
standards for their formulas they use
safe and effective ingredients like
retinol and vitamin C but it's at a
fraction of the cost of high-end skin
care it's of course cruelty free vegan
dermatologist tested and sensitive skin
friendly and sustainability is at the
heart of everything they do from
post-consumer recycled materials in
their packaging to maintaining a net
zero climate emission so you probably
see burst popped up on your Tick Tock or
Instagram feed their viral glass skin
delivered by the instant resurfacing
mask to their new gentle retinol body
lotion that has already sold out three
times it is the brand clean Beauty fans
can't get enough of right now and like
the fact that I use it is so me because
I'm such a tick talker
um so we obviously have a discount if
you go to versed skin.com toast and use
code toast to check out you'll get 10
off your purchase at v-e-r-s-e-d
skin.com
slash toast and use code toast love it I
like their lip oil I just wear lip liner
now and they're lip oil and it's like
the perfect gloss and that's what Haley
Bieber does the eye brightening cream
you would never know that Harry woke up
at 5 30 this morning by the way that's
what Haley Bieber does lip liner and
just like a bomb that's like such like a
clean girl like
I mean that's me like really literally
Haley Bieber Trucking like is it hard
for you when you're podcasting you're
like is it Shaggy or is it Haley
it's so difficult like actually you
don't even know like I'm sure you could
like comb through all the episodes and
I'd be like hey Jax
you know
yeah I could sense that I never want to
call you out on it because I don't want
to embarrass you no we don't do that
here we don't like call out other people
who flub words we would never do that
never because we are never sure
sweet sisters yesterday's dear toasters
two things I wanted to tell you one were
you surprised at how many people because
I don't know if you saw our reels like
200 people were commenting that they use
blankies like I did and because I had a
migraine yesterday I couldn't watch the
reels till this morning and I just I
felt upset that I was cut off in my
tirade because after seeing the comments
I think people needed to hear more of
what I was saying about how they have
deep psychological issues and they need
to transfer their dependency from their
you went harder no I no I did go as hard
as I could in the episode I wish there
was no interviews hard-going nature in
the real for all the people in the
comments who were like team blanky like
you should be embarrassed no but were
you surprised because you didn't really
believe me yeah you know what so many
people I was surprised I really thought
it was like you know this phrase orange
portion of society because my friends
and and the people that I'm close with I
do not know anyone who sleeps with a
blankie or a stuffed animal from
childhood mind you obviously there's
other people in the world and I don't
have like that many close friends who I
know what they sleep with but um usually
like
if say it's like one in eight people
have a blankie like I know eight people
closely right they don't have that [ __ ]
so I guess yes I was surprised but you
know what it's actually not that
surprising and I think that
um the fact that so many people
sleep with blankies still have them like
and feel attached to them like
underscore is a real issue are in our
society and with our generation and if
you generally play out all the time
and then the second thing that I thought
was really interesting was pertaining to
Rochella
um there was like a conspiracy theory in
one of our Facebook groups about it and
I thought it was a really interesting
take because people were like you know
some things aren't adding up
thought that the parents actually just
ate all the baked goods and in an effort
to like assuage himself of any like
blame they said there was roaches and
they were lying but interesting color
exterminator right after that is an
extreme length even I wouldn't do that
and I lie about everything agreed that's
what I was just about to say interesting
Theory until like the exterminators
called she's driving herself crazy and
the parents at that point should say
like nah we just ate them right and
Exterminators are like an expensive
hourly like service so you're really
gonna like take this lie all the way and
spend money just to admit to your
daughter that you ate her cookies right
I still think the roaches
Chef yeah
yeah it's a tough one we could really
write like a sequel to Ratatouille about
rochatouille around this story like it
sounds so good what would what would the
song be Rose
[Applause]
of all my dreams what would we name the
roach since Remy the rat this would have
to be like
Rochelle Rochelle Rochelle
Rochelle the roach
Justice for everyone listening to this
named Rochelle well their name is
Rochelle well you know I have a question
for
for the girlies parents who named them
Rochelle have you ever heard of the name
Rachel
have you ever heard of Michelle
actually maybe they liked both names so
much they said Rochelle no we should
really
um actually be praising Rochelle's
because it's our favorite combination of
two words Michelle and Rachel you know
we actually have a story today that is a
combination of two words our favorite
thing it's a new ad campaign and I know
you're gonna be really excited and is it
from Cascade because they still have a
lot of they have to a lot to make up to
me
because they don't have tissues yeah
like Cascade rolling out that Nationwide
insane campaign about dish issues and
not using dishes just adding that extra
syllable there do you know how much time
they could have saved if they took it
out
honestly I could never use Cascade again
it really stuck with me
I did use Cascade but now I've switched
to like a natural me too agent what do
you use I don't know something I got in
PR yeah I that's that might be like how
it starts for me I feel like now I've I
used to use like the heavy chemical
stuff but a lot of like these newer
Brands especially DTC and like
advertisers they send me stuff so I
don't like buy what I used to buy I'm
like oh well now I have um of course
Branch Basics love it and it's such
great stuff no it it does the job and
then we come on here and we spread the
word and we share code whatever is that
yeah welcome
hundred percent
so anything else you want to catch up on
before we dive in we've got really good
stories today yeah we do have really
good stories not much else I want to
catch up on since my day was marred by a
migraine how's Harry
he's good Mrs Auntie he's thinking about
me constantly as much as he can without
me making himself upset over it you know
so that's the thing by the way like
about being away from your loved ones
which is really something I never
experienced
until late in life is keeping in touch
is amazing but it's actually also like
makes it worse yeah two yeah to a degree
because you kind of have to like forget
about it in order for it to not bother
you but you and I are like so in touch
and so simpatic I don't think you ever
miss me no no excuse me that's true or
do you also when we FaceTime like I
don't have this insane desire to bite
your face and no you know what I mean
you won't even let me give you a hug
okay like you don't even like to be
touched
true or false
heart
but with Harry it's like I see him in
like I have to smother my face into his
like his neck like yeah so and not being
able to do that like I can do everything
I need to do with you on FaceTime I
can't do anything I actually need to do
with Harry on FaceTime therein lies the
problem with being away from your loved
ones I understand
so you actually like your whole life
being like very physical touch averse is
now working in your favor because
honestly I don't even miss you
okay like I get it I get it you miss me
so much and you're pushing me away my
God no actually I'm saying like I
actually really don't miss you because I
talk to you every every single day and
even when I see you like I come home I
come to your house from the airport we
don't even hug like you don't even like
to be hugged that's so true so our
relationship is really
we're coming to see you next week but
then like you are due for a visit so I
am due for a visit I do maybe cute like
January q1 I'll be there in the new year
that's by the way so tonight is my last
show of end log before the two next week
that I film so like it's kind of over
but not
um and my my 2023 is wide open and I'm
making 2023 like the year about me like
I did a lot of amazing things this year
but I worked incessantly
um because I was on tour and I'm
definitely taking a break from tour so
2023 is the year of me like I'm doing
things that I want I'm traveling like I
I literally just watched Sex in the City
too and I feel like this is the second
time this week I'm saying this but I
have the luxury of Designing my own life
I'm a business owner I don't have
children yet like that's not going to be
the case for much longer and 2023 is the
year of me like I'm going where I want
I'm doing what I want and I'm bringing
my podcast microphone with me where do
you want to go
I want to go to Harry's house and then I
want to go to kaylor's house manifest
like give me three places that you want
to go in 2023 number one being Paris no
I definitely do want to go to Europe
like Paris or London that's one okay
um
I would love to go on like a Caribbean
trip my favorite you know Virgin Islands
that's not like new for you but okay oh
it has to be new no like yeah yeah okay
it has to be new something that like you
didn't do in 2022 that you are
prioritizing in 23. Paris London
somewhere in Europe I've never been
two somewhere in the states I've never
been like a Wyoming or a Montana that's
especially because I told you one of my
goals in like the next couple of years
is I really want to go to all 50 states
and with Torah that makes it really easy
but I like probably will never tour in
like Wyoming or Montana I just don't
think there's like a big toaster
Community there so I would definitely
like to see that I don't know when the
best time of year to go is probably like
ski season
yeah it really is ski season if you ski
but since you don't like spring summer
would be really great and by the way
when you do plan that call me up out
there I definitely want to go to one of
those and then
three but you have to no this is what
you have to do this is your 2023
homework you have to watch Yellowstone
and then we will go to Montana
okay
do you want to learn about the places
that you're going you need to enjoy so
much more enjoyable I feel like when I
think back to like places that I've been
that I could give two shits about and
now I like would care so much yeah yeah
that's true
what's three okay not to like tell you
how to live your life but yeah
sounds like that's what you're doing
um I'm just like I'm looking out for you
for my third trip I don't know I'd
actually I feel really good about those
two like let's have to be maybe not a
trip but like something that you want to
do a skill oh I want to go to Stagecoach
I've missed it for like the last three
years great done those are my 20 those
are my resolutions I love that for you
yeah what about you
what do you want in the new year
I can't even think that far ahead
because right now I'm so close to
reaching one of my goals but once I
reach it like I'm taking a break from
goals oh I totally feel that and that's
getting my license like once I get my
license like I'm on Hiatus from goal
reaching road trip
that's my goal you should that's a good
one I feel like down in Florida there's
actually a lot of like good places you
can go with like within two three hours
Disney
oh my god when are you gonna take her to
Disney not until he's begging me to go
no it literally like that's a part of
Parenthood I refuse like I can't no but
the P The Toasters have really changed
my mind because they comment on it every
time we talk about it and they're like
it's [ __ ] lit at like you go to Epcot
you get dranks like the kids love it
it's good stuff getting drinks with my
kids does not sound fun it doesn't work
for me honestly
um just with my physical being but right
it's a good environment no but like for
me like if I'm gonna be drinking I'm
gonna be like popping my [ __ ] like
chain smoking like I can't do that in
front of my kids when the kids go to
sleep
that's that's when that's what I've
become a Disney adult
has when you become a Disney adult
totally enjoy by the way if you think
Jackie was tough on
people with blankies I can only imagine
what your like true thoughts are and
like people who are obsessed with Disney
and like the infantilization of not as
um my thoughts aren't as strong as yours
like when you make your case I'm like
yeah that's kind of weird but like okay
to go to Disney like once a year as an
adult to whatever it's your vacation
spend it how you want to every to like
be dependent on an inanimate object that
harks back to you being an infant no
Jackie you're underestimating what it is
like
people can have interests that I no but
I'm saying it's not it's not once a year
it's like literally moving to Orlando to
be near Disney going every weekend
literally spending every dollar you have
on photos with Mickey like it's an
obsession it's not like oh I love like
people we know a few people who love
Disney who let go as adults with their
friends like that's not what I'm talking
about yeah people who literally uproot
their lives to be closer to Orlando
people who spend their wedding money on
bringing Mickey and Minnie and not
having dinner I think yeah people who
forego catering just to have Mickey and
Minnie be there to cut their cake yeah
and then what did their guests say
Claudia
I want my dinner now that's what they
say
yeah
so it's just a little bit about me are
you ready to dive in
I am ready to dive into the fast five
stories that you need to know
are you sure yeah I was trying to figure
out a way to work at the Choice Brothers
in there but I didn't say it do so well
it's never too late to do it again
without further Ado where are the
stripes brother and they don't work
anymore who knows what they get into
during this hour except I know that
Bryce stands outside the door and waits
for me the entire time while I do the
show because he loves his mommy he just
doesn't want to work where's Theodora
he's at home actually he's on his walk
right now
um this what I'm about to do next is
just for the YouTube people so podcast
just give me a second without further
ado
I just stabbed you know sick that's
funny no I'm sorry that's not a dab
that's a whoa It's
whoa
that's so cool
I'm I'm so sick Bro oh my God stay away
from me I'm contagious I'm so sick I'm
foolish thank you get well soon
[ __ ]
um okay without further Ado hear the
Pastime stories that mclartia needs to
know
and today's episode is brought to you by
a sponsor I've been waiting to come back
because it is that time of year Where
Mrs Fields is doing her holiday gift
sets Mrs send me your holiday gift set
and she changed my life when I tell you
I'm not stopped thinking about this box
of cookies since last season of course
Mrs Fields cookies are great year-round
but there's something really special
about the holiday ones
so
I'm sorry I lost my copy you lost your
curds oh here sorry
um so this holiday season we want
everyone to have joy give joy feel Joy
ain't that right well who doesn't love
fresh from the oven melt in your mouth
cookies Mrs Fields has just what the
doctor ordered it is feel good giving at
its best Mrs Fields is going to wrap up
your delicious cookies in unique
creative packages that will thrill the
people who get them so I have a bunch of
people I need to send
um
gifts to you and the Mrs Fields cookies
I'm telling you I sent last year it is
first of all Nobody Does it like that I
know so like I'm feeling unique and
you're gonna like be stunted on all the
other gift givers the cookies are so
good there's like layers and layers of
sweet treats like you open the box you
think they're done but no you lift up
the thing there's more cookies
they're so delicious get one for
yourself obviously like send yourself a
gift just so that you can enjoy it while
also giving it to all the important
people in your life they have tons of
different varieties of cookies classic
flavors like chocolate chip but also
salted caramel frosted cookies brownie
bites so there's something that everyone
will love it is the perfect gift for
grandparents parents kids friends
co-workers clients it is something that
will thrill any person at any age and
whatever their taste is and we know for
over 45 years Mrs Fields has perfected
that fresh baked Gourmet treats Mrs
Fields is a girly that you can trust we
are girls you can trust everything is so
yummy the packaging is gorgeous and
right now Mrs Fields is giving the best
deal available only to our podcast
listeners get 25 off everything
site-wide when you go to mrsfields.com
toast that's mrsfields.com toast
exclusive deal just for us 25 off
everything at Mrs f-i-e-l-d-s.com
slash toast mrsfields.com toast you will
thank us later on that one today's
episode is also brought to you
by diff eyewear so diff eyewear sunnies
are pulling double duty for us when I
wake up not feeling Flawless the
oversized trendy Shades can handle
anything that life has to throw at me so
we all know that oversized sunglass look
is very glamorous and it can make every
outfit into an actual fashion moment but
I really love them because they
transcend fashion and they become a
functional need they look Fab they can
hide your puffy under eyes if you're
hungover you have a migraine your
mascara is running dip eyewear has you
covered they have so many Chic oversized
stiff Shades like the Goldies the Glam
Becky twos they really get the job done
we like to call them our hangover Shades
because after too much fun on a Saturday
night heading out the next day you'll
feel your red puffy eyes on fleek if you
have a headache the diff eyewear
oversized sunglasses are here to help
if you have a bad breakup you spent all
night crying over your ex you don't want
to leave your apartment don't worry Jeff
eyewear has you covered they will rescue
you when you want to save face and make
your outfit a bit more Fab so Jif
eyewear is just the affordable sunglass
solution I'm always on the hunt for like
oversized like huge sunglasses that make
my face look nice and small I have
gotten a ton of different pairs from dip
eyewear they're super affordable they're
really well made and they're stunning so
visit dip eyewear.com toast for a chance
to win a thousand dollars cash and score
your own dip sunnies for a year plus you
can score a sweet deal for the holidays
they're offering an amazing 50 off on
their website right now which is
diffeyware.com toast and make sure you
check that out for a chance to win a
thousand dollars cash and score your own
diff sunnies for an entire year
thank you mclared you're welcome okay
our first story is a couple Royal Tings
because it's a battle of the couple's
first up Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
share their dramatic trailer for their
Netflix show
calling it a trailer is a bit of an
exaggeration it's a video montage it's
technically a trailer because they're
promoted it's a video they're promoting
the new show they have a lot of images
and a couple quotes so here it is Megan
and Harry are finally giving fans a look
at their highly anticipated Netflix
docu-series right in the middle of
William and Kate's Boston trip which we
will get to the trailer for Harry and
Megan drop Thursday morning and shows
photos taken throughout their
relationship including images of Megan
looking glum at Royal events and even
crying and brief footage of um their new
life in California the quotes include
Harry narrating saying quote no one sees
what's happening behind closed doors
then Megan asks when the stakes are this
High doesn't it matter doesn't it make
more sense to hear our story from us
and then there's a bunch of black and
white images from them over the years
some of like things that we've seen the
umbrella picture obviously kicked
everything off but it was exciting of
intimate personal moments and what's so
crazy is like we never see you know
selfies from the couples because they
don't really like use Instagram like the
rest of us but there are still people
and they take photos of themselves they
have iPhones they have all of these
pictures that like I just can't I never
imagined seeing them in this context
like at a photo booth like doing a kiss
in a photo booth and so it's really
it's like nice to humanizes human yeah
and I'm sure even like William and Kate
have pictures like this that will never
see
um because that's just like not how they
the pictures are all like you know
portraits and stuff like that or
paparazzi photos so to see them like in
Royal life behind the scenes it was cool
um so the trailer really gave us nothing
like let's be honest it was a video
montage with like one scene of Megan and
one scene of Harry in like a
confessional so I still don't really
even know what the documentary is like
about I'm assuming it's like a tell-all
of the last couple of years
um
so it's like a bit of a tease so I I'm
like I'm wanting more but what I found
to be the most interesting was there was
a picture of William and Kate and that
was like when the music stopped and
became like dark like I I think that was
like a signal that this is not gonna be
a friendly documentary of course and the
picture of them they're like scowling
and looking nastily something and what
are they looking at what is that picture
from exactly it's obviously going to be
if there was ever if they were trying to
mend the relationship you can tell from
this documentary that's not the
direction that they're headed in
I when I all up until today like I
thought that their docu-series was just
gonna be like here's us and our life in
California almost like a reality show
but I feel like this is a documentary
about the last five years since Megan
joined the family they've exited and now
they live in California which I guess
makes more sense and is a little more
dignified than a reality show agreed and
so Megan says when the seek circus High
doesn't it make sense to hear from us
yes like there's so much going on
there's so much that said like let them
just say it in their own words
especially now that they can that
they're no longer working Royals but
then it just reminds me like they did an
Oprah interview Megan has a podcast like
we've heard everything I feel like
they've said it all so what are they
going to be saying and if it's so major
why didn't they say it at Oprah no so
yes that
and I just don't know how many times you
can tell your story because Harry's also
writing a book
yeah so it's kind of like I'm is it
crazy or like is anyone else getting a
little bit of fatigue from this yeah and
I feel like with everything that they do
it is so edited produced even you know
her podcast as we were saying yesterday
this documentary like it doesn't get
more
curated than right all of these pictures
that they've shared it's their story
like and so how many times are we going
to hear the same side of the story right
well her podcast really uh
didn't tell any story it's not even
about it's not about Royals it's not
about no but sometimes she talks about
so every episode is an archetype that
people used to describe women so then
she'll talk about her experience with
that word and a lot of times it does
have to do with things that happened in
the last five years yeah but it wasn't
like uh it was it's not like every week
we're going week by week about what I
experience when I joined the world it
wasn't a tell-all the Oprah interview
was a tell-all I'm assuming the book is
a tell-all and I'm assuming the
documentary is a tell-all and if all
that's just a lot of tell-offs
yeah for someone who has a weekly
platform where you can share what's
going on and how you're feeling like
when I tell you I'll be the first person
to watch this like I'm so curious of
course I'm just like am I like so
delusional that like I just feel like
there's like um until this documentary
comes out like I feel like there's like
a smidgen of Hope even though did you
see I had seen a rumor that was like
totally unsubstantiated that Kate was
gonna be on archetypes
literally that we never I know I know
but like I'm holding out hope you know
that would never happen no and the
season finale of archetypes just came
out honestly I feel like I could say
with certainty that Kate would sooner be
on the toast than archetypes honestly
totally I was a betting woman I would
place that bet sooner oh my God by the
way that's literally such a good bet
like if if we said if somebody said to
Kate like gun to your head you have to
go on one of these podcasts she would
choose us yeah
but like because even if she were to sit
one they're never gonna Kate actually
has done a podcast in the past so it's
like not that crazy but they're never
going to sit down and tell their side of
the story because that's not what being
a royal is and if she were ever to do
that and to get into the weeds it
wouldn't be on Megan's platform it would
be just somewhere neutral right like the
toast right
so even though we're not neutral because
we like love the crown yes no we're
sorry we're not neutral but I'm just
saying like um yeah neither one of
theirs yeah it would be an away game the
way I think about this now is like Queen
has passed away we know Harry's
relationship with his dad is really bad
so they really have nothing to lose so
I'm assuming it's going to be brutal no
I think that what they have to lose now
it's the titles for their kids yeah
that's the one thing that Charles is
holding out
um and
even though things are really bad like I
I still think before this movie comes
out and before the book comes out
it's not impossible to say that one day
they might make amends it's not
irreparable right now it it might take
years but if they never
talk [ __ ] again they could maybe like
come back from this in a few years once
the docu-series is out there and the
book is out there and then he's in like
a three book contract so there's got to
be more that he has to share yeah
um then I think
it's done yeah though it is pretty done
but you never know because sometimes
with family family it's thaws it just it
does like you can't say when it will
happen just one day like you wake up and
and it has thawed a hundred percent a
hundred percent so that's why it's it's
not impossible but I don't know what
lies in that documentary and I don't
know what lies in that manuscript yeah
it kind of reminds me of even like the
season of the crown with Diana where
there was a few interviews that she did
and like the first one was like bad but
then everyone like got used to it and it
was just like whatever but then it
wasn't until Martin beshear that I was
like okay now we will uh we now
encourage it we will encourage a divorce
you two can no longer be together even
though like all along over the years
like there were things that were bad but
we're gonna still make it work we're a
family and then it was like too far gone
yeah no it's very similar and I just
feel like if this start if this trailer
had dropped and there was never that
like William and Kate photo and music
change moment you could make a case that
this is just about me and Harry and
they're telling their story but there is
clearly you know more that they're going
to share and it's going to be
anti-family or perhaps we're looking too
much into it but it's because they
literally gave us nothing in the trailer
no no there was literally nothing
confusing about that moment yeah yeah no
totally like so I can't wait to watch
this like I'm what but they did they say
coming soon we didn't even get a date
but it is coming in December that's the
latest that I had heard
great to watch with a family
added to the list of holiday viewing
where the crawdad's saying the whale the
whale Megan and Harry you know what we
do have a list oh and
oh spirited or whatever that movie is
spirited that Will Ferrell movie oh yeah
yeah the holiday movie with Will Ferrell
and Ryan Reynolds
hold on crawdad when you go home for the
holidays and you need someone to watch
oh wow we have a lot of really good
oh no but we were joking about watching
Harry and Megan with your family why I
don't know not everyone cares no I feel
like and one way or another like
everyone kind of cares okay I'll add it
I think it's probably Terry and Megan
and not Megan and Harry By the way
well that's true what's it called the
name of it is Harry and Megan
that's weird because like everyone calls
it Megan and Harry
no it can go either way so I'm surprised
that they didn't lead with Megan because
like that's just more she's the main
character here no and it's like very
patriarchal for the man to be first no
so true but is it like a royal thing
like does he have to be introduced first
I don't think so
they don't even live in the UK this is
like a formal uh like it's a title of
the show no I don't know I don't know
I feel like they could have done like
more of the title
what would you have liked to see
I don't know it's not my job to be
creative it's Netflix
okay
Lex bear you know it's bear such a great
name right
are you ready for oh our next story is
just Royal story subset B which is that
William Kate are in the states they went
to a Boston Celtics game last night and
they flew commercial here I saw British
Airways they flew commercial which just
underscores my point that if the Future
King of England and future Queen can fly
commercial then all of these celebrities
who are talking about climate change can
fly commercial no I was really I was not
expecting that I was I was wanted to
look at pictures of them so I just like
Googled it and it said British Airways
but I'm like you're kidding I mean I'm
sure they bought out the whole first
class cabin but still they didn't
because fellow passengers were taking
pictures
you're kidding maybe they had like extra
seats for their security and stuff but
right they bought out the whole cabin
do you think they like hated that
no no I actually I don't think so I'm
sure it's like nicer for them to apply
on the Royal jet but I think also that
they want people to see them they're
leading by example yeah and that like I
think that they I think it's fine okay
yeah oh so uh the story uh William and
Kate were cheered on by sports fans at
the Celtics game last night uh the
Celtics played the Miami Heat on
Wednesday and they were both received by
the owner of the Celtics before sitting
Courtside the couple arrived in town on
Wednesday for a three-day trip which
will come culminate in the earth shot
prize ceremony on Friday so there's like
they're here to do work for like climate
change like they really could not have
flown private so true or else we'd be
roasting them I'm also shocked to see
them Courtside and like not in a suite
it feels like you know it would be a
safety issue they're just like with the
peeps with the commoners yeah but
I think they probably have their
security like working
you know tirelessly and I think the
image of them being Courtside is better
for them than the image of them being in
a suite yeah do you think the players
like were at all phased by it's like
really big deal I feel like sitting
presidents like don't go to basketball
games like it's not a thing that really
happens
yeah I don't know maybe some players who
are into the crown right maybe they
don't care some people just some people
legit don't care about the royal family
like especially in America I used to be
one of these people right right it's so
crazy
yeah it's crazy it was cute that they're
like it was cute normies and they're
coming to this event like Billy eilish
is performing Ellie Goulding who also
performed at their wedding yeah no they
love Ellie Goulding I mean who doesn't I
mean somebody dm'd me last night that
Kate and William were at the Garden and
I'm like you're [ __ ] kidding me but
they were at TD Garden
there's only one Garden yeah let's be
real do not call TD Garden the garden
it's the Garden of Eden 100 God bless
so by the way do you think like the
timing of this release has anything to
do with William and Kate being in the
U.S like Harry and Megan like a circle
yeah it's just my country now you saw
them find commercial and sit in
Courtside in your hearts warming towards
them here's a trailer to remind you who
the real prince and princess of the US
are right I feel like the timing is kind
of interesting yeah I I would say
considering there are so many days of
the year and then on a three-day trip
and by the way that was what a lot of
the rumors about Kate and Megan's like
initial issues with each other were with
that like Kate's team or Megan's team
like were planned like their PR teams
were being shady that was like a huge
contentious thing that was like written
like rumors about rumored about them so
it seems like this is kind of playing
into that rumor because I definitely
found the timing to be interesting like
like literally William and Kate haven't
been to the state since 2014. the day
they get here the next morning the
trailer drops of course yeah no I don't
think that's oh and when they were on
the plane there's another story about
some uh woman's Twitter
the um with Camilla Camilla thank you I
couldn't remember her name so it's like
I just find the timing interesting yeah
yeah I think that they don't mind if
William and Kate's us visit is
overshadowed is overshadowed or just
like putting a dent in it yeah yeah but
it's not like they're doing a whole tour
like you know of the entire country like
we've seen them do on the crown
sometimes like it's just three days like
it's only Boston hearts and minds are
going to be really changed by them going
to Boston for three days no and I feel
like at this point like either you love
Harry and Megan or you love William and
Kate like there's like people I think
people have chosen their sides yeah I
think so too
so I don't know how much can be done to
like change public perception
yeah
so looking forward to that yeah
next up a little romance drama over at
GMA oh God yes those stars to lovers GMA
anchors Amy roback and TJ Holmes his
romance is revealed as the two married
or formerly married separated co-hosts
are seen cozying up at a New York City
Bar spending a romantic weekend away
Upstate and holding hands in an Uber so
Daily Mail can remember they know that
what how do they know they were holding
hands in an Uber photos the driver
there's pictures of them
there's pictures of them Upstate and
she's leaning over to put something in
the trunk and he's touching her booty
no but how do they know they were
holding hands in the back of an Uber
um they were holding hands in an Uber
like the they're getting out of the Uber
holding hands so oh so somebody took a
photo from flick from the street yes
from the street yeah okay okay thank you
there's just all these like photos of
them in various States and days and oh
I'm sorry there's a picture of them from
the window
and you could see them holding hands by
the way who the [ __ ] like would be able
to recognize like a random GMA host on
the street
these pictures kind of look like they're
being tailed like there's some of them
in a bar and I guess if you watch GMA
every morning and you were in that bar
like you oh my god Jackie you're 100
right it's like a pi yeah like maybe um
a publication got tipped off that
they're having an affair and so they
started following them and getting new
pictures maybe one of their spouses had
a feeling
literally sent gotta Pi got photos and
sold them to page six that's what I
think yeah maybe it's one of them
because to see someone getting out of a
car and have enough time to grab a photo
of it on your phone like that's insane
no these pictures look and then they're
abstain and there's pictures so this
person can follow them Upstate like
someone was trying to capture evidence
of their Affairs so true so true
um but honestly the pictures are like
sweet and GMA has put out a statement
saying that they were both separated
from their spouses before they got
together
um the Deets are this
Amy and TJ's friendship has evolved into
a full-blown romantic relationship
off-screen the two co-anchors whose
on-screen chemistry captivated audiences
after they joined gma's third hour in
2020 can be seen together enjoying
flirty post-work drinks at a New York
City Bar earlier this month they have
also been snap spending alone time
together in each other's apartments and
shacking up in the secluded Cottage in
Upstate New York for a romantic getaway
two weeks before Thanksgiving according
to insiders the two are said to have
gone from co-stars to lovers in June
when they were in London together
covering the Queen's Diamond Jubilee for
ABC oh my God it always comes back to
the queen 100 percent
uh TJ had been married to his wife
Marilee with whom he shared the daughter
since 2010 and the same year Amy had
married her actor husband Andrew shoe so
now
um sources are saying that they were
dating in the open after separating from
their spouses in August
but the other source says that they
started being romantic in June so if
they separated in August but this GMA
plan is saying that like they were
separated first and then they got
together
they said this was two consenting adults
who were each separated they both broke
up with their spouses in August within
weeks of each other the relationship
didn't start until after that listen I
would believe it
if I now wasn't convinced that somebody
was following them like that makes it
seem nefarious not like totally
conveniently timed
yeah I agree with you oh and by the way
now they have to get married of course
but I don't know if I'm just like toxic
obviously I hate to see a marriage
breakup um especially when there's kids
like
it's terrible but this is like a meat
cute a ship so [ __ ] hard
um I hope that they continue to like
host the hour together be in love like
they need to weather this PR storm
either make them or break them I think
that this is really cute that's funny
just am I the only one I don't know
enough about these people I've never
seen their show and like it's not like
you know one's the boss and and it's not
like it's not like you know Chris Cuomo
is being with an intern like right
equals they work together they do the
show together like but like not Chris
what's his name no I uh Governor Andrew
Andrew oh my God I literally I was just
using like another name but no I'm not I
understand I know Chris was never with
an intern and no if he was that's not
why he even got back no he got fired
because he was he was helping his
brother right right right right right
um
so it's not like a Matt Lauer situation
right no no I agree like there's no
there's no um these are I stated these
are two consenting adults who got
together now if they did cheat on their
spouse he's like that is wrong but again
that's not a crime it's frowned upon and
that's like what they're choosing to do
in their personal lives and so you can I
guess judge them for that but I don't
think either one of them should like not
come back to the show no no no I agree
but if they do break up it'll be hella
weird well then they'll move around the
hours and stuff yeah but I think that
they should give this a shot I think
this is going to be great for the third
hour I think people are going to be
tuning in to like see like chemistry if
I was someone who's been watching GMA
for the last few months I would go back
and look at those August episodes and be
like yeah can I tell a difference I
agree no this is like a PR moment for
this random third hour I think it's a
great moment except I saw today that TJ
did the third hour by himself
oh no maybe she's taking it harder than
he is or maybe the network just wants to
see how things shake out but if anybody
from GNA is listening like get those two
together on the Edge Let's embrace it
embrace the moment they they they didn't
just like hook up they've had this
relationship going on I think it's all
good no Jackie's a hundred percent right
100 right let's turn this negative to a
positive 100
like the pictures aren't like
embarrassing or anything like they're
really sweet yeah
is like the public will truly never know
whether it was an affair or perfectly
timed and to be honest until we have
solid proof I guess we have no choice
but to believe them
yeah exactly and it could always be like
you know you think this way I think like
he said she said unless a spouse speaks
out that's what will happen
but when I tell you I've never heard of
either of these people and now I'm like
invested that's good PR like that's what
they say there's no such thing as bad
press yeah but she does look really
familiar I feel like she was doing
something recently like maybe even the
Thanksgiving Day Parade and I saw her
maybe yeah so I think they could be the
next hosting Duo like you Kathy Lee and
Hoda well are there a lot of married
co-hosting Duos I can only think of the
one uh Minka and Joe yes
that's what comes to mind
yeah
I think it goes well for them
I think so the show is called the
morning Joe right
it's like what about me it's giving
patriarchy
it is
well thank you for that you're welcome
yeah we could just briefly pause before
we move on just to let everyone know
that today's episode is sponsored by
Perfect bar don't go nuts this holiday
season fuel yourself with the perfect
bar the original refrigerated protein
bar made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
and they're all so good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love like the dark chocolate chip peanut
butter which is a favorite of mine the
sea salt perfect bar which I know is a
favorite of Jackie's super delicious
they have cookie dough texture that's
creamy and full of flavor and you keep
them in the refrigerator which honestly
is making all other bars look bad
because I had never thought about how
kind of gross it is that like these are
supposed to be like fresh nuts grains
like and
we're keeping them in the pantry so far
knows that it will be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time they're offering
you a chance to try their refrigerated
protein bars for free here's how it'll
work sign up for email or text and
upload a picture of your receipt from
your local grocery store and they'll
reimburse you for the cost of one bar
it'll go directly into your venmo or
PayPal account which is pretty cool all
you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today it's perfect snacks.com toast
to get a free perfect bar today happy
snacking I know you love the perfect
bars because you are perfect to me I do
I grabbed one yesterday because we were
doing podcasts back to back didn't have
time to sit down for a full meal but
needed my nutrients ASAP and it was so
tasty and I was genuinely I did my
Hunger didn't hit me again until way
later so I love the perfect bar it is
the perfect bar today's episode is also
brought to you by Tommy John imagine
getting everyone on your list the
perfect gift well shop Tommy John's
cyber sale Cyber Monday sale right now
and spread the joy of cozy okay I'm a
pajama drama like snob I have this blue
set of pajamas from Tommy John they are
perfect they're literally perfect the
material is so thin but so warm but it's
like not gonna keep making me hot I have
been obsessed since I got in the mail
like two weeks ago and Tommy John you're
that much more comfortable so you can do
everything better you could shop Tommy
John Cyber Monday sale give the gift of
comfort to everyone on your list
including yourself they have new Tommy
John underwear loungewear and pajamas
with over 18 million pairs sold giving
Tommy John has become a holiday
tradition 97 of women and men love
getting a gift from Tommy John and
that's why Tommy John doesn't just have
customers they have Fanatics what I tell
you I can't sing the Praises of these
pajamas enough also I got like a nice
very relaxing
um bra it's like not a bra it's more of
like a I call it a relaxation bra it's
like a bralette almost Ben calls it the
relaxation bra like when I walk in he's
like oh my God relaxation bra because
like it's a very like low-key you wear
it when you're relaxing exactly so if
you want to shop the Cyber Monday sale
at Tommy John do that now and get 33 off
everything plus free shipping at
tommyjohn.com toast it's one of Tommy
John's biggest sales of the Year 33 off
everything plus free shipping at
tommyjohnjohn.com slash toast Seaside
for details
t-o-m-m-y-j-o-h-n.com slash toast great
thank you so much you're welcome are you
ready for our next story that Kim
Kardashian planted in TMZ oh yeah I saw
my thoughts were exactly the same like
how convenient The Source had such you
know vindicating information for your
girl Kim and Insider information Kim
Kardashian declined new campaign offer
from Balenciaga before breaking her
silence on the child sex controversy
they call it like the BDSM controversy
no it's just that's what it is we're not
mad about BDS and we're mad about the
children no BDSM is in fashion all the
time and nobody cares uh you're putting
it on children that's when we're going
to be like what yep
Kim Kardashian announced she's quote
reevaluating her future with Balenciaga
but it appears she's made up her mind
declining an offer from the brand and
ditching outfit she was said to wear at
upcoming events sources with direct
knowledge of the situation told TMZ the
design house presented Kim and offered
to do a 2023 Balenciaga campaign before
the controversial child BDSM ads went
live we're told once Those ads went
public Kim made the decision to reject
the offer even before releasing a
statement on the issue where she didn't
really distance herself from the brand
not only that TMZ sources say AKA Chris
and Kim said that Kim had plans to wear
Balenciaga outfits at events she's
attending in coming months but she's
pulled the plug in contact with other
designers for new options she's a hero
so as just to remind you then so Kim
allegedly according to TMZ and Chris and
Kim Kim turned down she saw the campaign
with the kids she turned down future
pending offer that she had and then she
released a statement you know denouncing
child sex abuse and normalizing children
in inappropriate sexual situations
though she didn't tell the public that
she's no longer going to be working with
Balenciaga and that she declined this
campaign and then people were not really
here for her paltry response to the
child pedophilic normalization that
Balenciaga put forth and then it is
revealed that Kim actually he's not even
working with them and and just she
didn't tell us that but she wasn't going
to be working with them after she saw
those images anyway I mean the
Kardashians are supposed to be better
than this they've been in this industry
for a long time they've navigated many
scandals and like this is just like a
hatchet job it's really reflecting
poorly on Kim I think even from some of
her biggest fans and like biggest
apologists
so I don't know where we go from here
but like this
turnt ass article isn't helping
no it's not helping I agree this is a
patchy job and they're supposed to be
better and savvier than this and I don't
know what the truth is I think that I
think Kim thought it wouldn't be as big
as fans and the way that they perceive
her as much as it has and I guess
sometimes it is hard to know like what's
going to be that thing I people get the
Kardashians hate all the time but like
the fans we are there like we're tried
and true and we're like you guys just
hate and you hate for no reason and even
like the biggest fans are like this is
disappointing and it it's really
like change things for me honestly
because you want to be coming from us no
because you want to know I really think
why it's changed something for me is
because what people have said over the
years about Kim which I feel like is so
unfair it's like the Kardashians are
just like obsessed with Fame obsessed
with money and they've like no values
and it's like that's not true because
you watch a show and like you know these
girls like their family like they're
emotional like they care about things
they care about one another they do a
lot of good work
um and then something like this happens
where it's like so clearly an issue over
like it's like values or money and it
felt like Kim chose the money and this
is like such a like an unethical
situation and it almost feels like
everything anyone has said about her is
like being validated and it's like damn
like even at the situation where the
right answer is so obvious and it
doesn't even require that much from you
it's you ending like a [ __ ] campaign
maybe you'll lose money and her not
doing even the bare minimum it's like
it's so disappointing like it really is
from someone who like I feel like we've
like really looked up to yeah I I don't
feel exactly the same as you like I
don't feel like this confirms everything
that people have said about Kim and like
the Kardashians being money obsessed
because for some reason and I might be
totally wrong about this but I don't
think Kim has made that much money
working with Balenciaga I don't think
it's her biggest paycheck I don't think
that they have that much money to pay
her especially compared to like what
Kmart could pay right I think for her
it's about Prestige you know being
obsessed with being accepted by the
Fashion World right and Balenciaga has
because she was rejected for so many
years she was rejected and then she was
accepted as Kanye's plus one right and
then she was accepted on her own but now
she is the sitting chairwoman of the
fashion industry right next to Anna
Wintour and like doesn't want to give
that up I think what Kim doesn't realize
is like for us lay people like she is
the fashion industry what she wears we
all look to I feel like also there was
this weird storyline where she like
doesn't have a sense of style and and
Balenciaga became her sense of style and
one I think it's it's pretty ugly but
maybe there's like a piece of her that
thinks it's the [ __ ] and like she can't
wear anything else and like this is who
she is
um I don't know what it is that's
keeping her
with them I I can't figure it out I
don't think it's money I think yes I
have a little bit money it's like a yes
The Prestige I don't know what it is
that no I don't think she wants to be
perceived by like high fashion as like a
whistleblower oh that's so true that
like she turned on Valencia because
everybody else like no one else nobody
else has Anna said anything no Nicole
Kidman like nobody has none of them take
away the Balenciaga spokespeople the any
other houses said anything creative
directors magazine editors no no Kim
doesn't want to be perceived as a
whistleblower who went hard against
Balenciaga yeah it might it would damage
her reputation in the industry that's
supposed to protect they they're all
problematic yeah John Gagliano that
could be what it is then and everyone's
wearing John Galliano like I mean even
you everyone like loves her Coco Chanel
was like a Nazi girly like the fashion
industry is hella problematic and like
it's not a thing that you talk about
so if Kim's going to talk about it she's
no longer going to be the it girl of
high fashion okay
so that's probably what it is but
if she starts to see that like
it's really fans affecting her fans and
like her true fans Not Just Like fair
weather fans or haters then I think that
that audience is much more important to
her than the high fashion audience so
maybe that's why she's course correcting
a little bit now and maybe she won't
work with valenciaga but isn't going to
come out against them she'll plant a
story that's like hey fans I'm doing the
right thing but I'm not gonna say
something crazy about Balenciaga that
way I can have my cake and eat it too
it's coward cowardly yeah and this does
nothing as a fan who's like turning this
does nothing to bring me back yeah
yeah
yeah so who would have thought who would
have thought
be some sex teddy bears that just came
between us and Kim no totally she has to
do more there was a story yesterday that
the family had like a family meeting at
Travis Barker Studio did you see that no
I don't know why the Press like I said
it was a family meeting when it was like
all of them showed up to Travis's Studio
they were there and it was the sun was
out and they left when the sun was down
and like what were they doing there if
not to like have a meeting I feel like
it was like a crisis meeting about this
the headlines didn't even mention
Balenciaga they said it was a family
meeting about Kim's settlement what
no Kim settlement news is so
uninteresting to me they're trying to
make it interesting because so people
are talking about Kim settlement like
who gives a [ __ ] about Kim settlement
like it's not like it changes anything
in either of their lives you're so right
the way that like all the details are
like being pushed out like on some
you're so right they're trying to make
200 000 a month
don't care you're both billionaires
doesn't matter who pays for the kids
like the kids will be paid for yeah no
I'm not worried about the kids getting
you know their tuition checks even when
Kim and Kanye first announced their
divorce not for nearly a second did I
wonder who was getting what jacket
you're so [ __ ] right like they'll
each have a billion no matter how you
guys don't be tricked like don't be
tricked into caring about the settlement
you're right I literally don't care
about the settlement and so they had a
meeting they had a meeting they had the
settlement um but I think it was a
meeting about uh what to do about this
and it's a TMZ article came out
with the inside info I think that's they
think this is a solution if anybody's
listening I don't think this is a
solution no
so lame like can we supposed to be
cooler than this like she's the most
famous she doesn't need anyone she
doesn't want for anything like she
doesn't have to kowtow to people like
just go with do what's right no and like
you could be the coolest person in the
world but if you don't stand up for kids
like you're not cool anymore you're
nasty I agree especially because like
the kids are like the maybe the one
group that like don't have
like can't speak for themselves like
they don't have platforms like they're
just being kids so like it's for the
adults to speak for them yeah everyone
else can go and get their microphone and
share their piece no you're so right
so that's where I draw the line the
campers
are you ready for our next story
it's some great advertising news Lindsay
Lohan gets back in her mean girl Santa
suit to make dirty sodas in the new
Pepsi ad so Lindsay is the new face of
Pepsi and they are sharing their festive
Campaign which is called pilk and
cookies now it's positive and negative
so it's pilk because it's Pepsi and milk
she drinks and that's called a dirty
soda so that's really gross but she says
in the campaign it's Pepsi and milk pilk
cute but by the way like Lindsay being
in a Pepsi commercial is giving 2003
icon era like Brittany and the Pepsi
commercials like when Pepsi's
commercials like Beyonce pink and
Christine Aguilera I think
um like this is Iconic it's really I
kind of gets crazy how Lindsay can go
through so much like do so many things
the craziest stories and then she just
sits down and drinks a Pepsi and says
one line I'm like nothing's changed no
it's so true especially like I watched
just bits and pieces of her new movie
she really looks great like she really
looks the same I'm so excited to watch
her new movie add it to the list yeah
it's a list what's it called I don't
know but just search Lindsay Lohan on
Netflix yeah
um I've been meaning to watch it I'm so
excited and what's so I think iconic
about her aside from everything else is
her voice her voice is so distinct and
even though so much about her has
changed over the years like that voice
takes you back and it's like actually an
amazing point and her hair
no but her hair has changed over the
years so many no but she's back to red
when you watch a redhead you could dye
your hair and then you can go back to
Red like how does that work I thought
once it's like
no your hair grows
okay but that's not what happened here
what do you mean like she used to be
blonde she didn't grow like all fresh
new hair from her roots to her tips
I think she like died it back oh that's
an interesting point you know that's I
think like at some point she probably
had like her roots coming back so she
died her hair red and then waited for
the rest to keep growing and trimming
and grow growing and okay maybe that's
what happened here because it's been so
long but I feel like it's General
redheads like go back and forth and it's
like how do you get your original color
back no that's actually a really good
point maybe the original color is like a
Dye like a
no they're still a natural redhead but
the color they're having is like a red
dye right but that's what I'm saying
it's like wow no that's just a real
thing yeah
so that's some cute marketing news I
will not be drinking soda and milk and
it's pretty nasty but it's got us
talking it's absolutely vile
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes a story that mclartya
requested oh yeah
it's a McLarty original
yeah I'm ready
a radio host has dubbed Teresa Giudice
the rudest person ever after their
interview so before we discuss read I
read the article read the whole article
because they have like a transcript in
there and then Andy speaks on it too
Boston radio personality Billy Costa
slam Trudy's Teresa Giudice as quote an
idiot quote nothing and quote a monster
after she allegedly attacked him in a
live interview on Monday she was easily
hands down the rudest person I've ever
interviewed the radio host said on his
show after the interview ended the show
is Billy and Lisa in the morning the
real houses of New Jersey star appeared
on the program to event to promote an
event she's co-hosting in Lynn
Massachusetts however the interview took
a turn once Billy asked Teresa about
writing her book turning the tables
after her 11-month stint in prison in
2015. he asked her quote Teresa we know
you spent some time in prison but you
came out of prison and wrote a book a
bestseller about your time in prison and
did it focus a lot on the food in prison
that was his question she then took told
the radio hosted she quote really didn't
want to talk about that he said sorry
she said I don't know if you know this
but I'm a four times New York selling
best-selling New York Times best-selling
author he then tried to move on he
assured her that he didn't know that and
then tried to move on from the
confrontation and asked about the event
she was promoting but Teresa wasn't
ready to let it go
she said quote we're going to have a
good time and it's all about being
positive right and not negative you
should learn some of that she told
bluntly to the radio host and he replied
that he'd work on that
one of the show's other hosts Justin
then chimed in and argued that they
weren't being negative since her book is
part of her bio which was given to them
by her publicist she said quote I have a
podcast called Namaste [ __ ] and you
should listen to it and learn how to be
a little more Namaste then her rep cut
her off and encouraged the hosts to come
to her clients event after Teresa hung
up following the short phone interview
the hosts wasted no time in sharing
their thoughts on the star quote I did
time in prison too and you said quote
yeah you did time in prison but you got
out you wrote a successful book which it
was it was a huge book Justin revealed
while the other co-hosts agreed that it
was supposed to be from a positive
perspective Justin also claimed that
they stayed away from all the other
topics they were told not to ask about
including Teresa's strain relationship
with her brother Joe Gorga and the hate
she's received on social media for
wearing Balenciaga amid their
controversy wow I thought that was
really interesting then Billy said I
don't even want a coffee with Teresa
Giudice if when he was asked if he was
still planning on going to her event her
Teresa has yet to comment directly on
the remarks the hosts made about her
but her publicist her publicity said
quote I think Mr Costa needs to work on
being a bit more Namaste like Teresa is
he seemed like he was looking for a
confrontation or to have his moment I
would recommend he listened to Teresa's
podcast Namaste [ __ ] so he can work
on himself and learn how to properly
treat guests on his show then Andy
addressed the controversy on his Sirius
XM show his executive print uh sorry he
asked the first caller what the what
what was said and asked her since they
had to say something to get her to be
that Rude the caller Double Down stating
that Teresa was rude right off the bat
and Andy seemed shocked responding
that's what's happening in Boston this
morning I like it
okay so this to me this is so layered
because like one uh I completely believe
that this man who by the way a lot of
Boston toasters were like talking about
it like he's a huge deal like he's like
about radio Legend like who's probably
interviewed like a lot of really famous
people like I 100 believe him when he
says that she's the rudest person he's
ever interviewed like she's literally a
monster
um two I actually don't think he was
being nefarious at all and I kind of
love that they threw in her face all the
things they were told not to talk about
and didn't talk about and if prison is
in your bio then prison's in your bio no
here's what I find so interesting about
this story obviously this guy does not
watch Real Housewives he just lives in
the world he doesn't watch Teresa Teresa
lives by her own set of Worlds she's
made everyone on the show abide by these
set of rules they're fraught with
contradictions and things that make no
sense and then Teresa like walks into
the real world expects everyone to like
play by her rules and her sensitivities
and this person is just a regular
[ __ ] person who has no idea who she
is read her bio she wrote a book about
prison let's talk about that book since
we can't talk about this list of other
things right has no idea that that's a
trigger for her and instead of like just
answering the question and being normal
about it she's like wait why won't you
call it camp like I do and so when you
are away
you said you said I went to jail oh my
gosh you've you've triggered me no but
this is also like the environment that
Bravo Fosters I mean Andy literally said
I like it like there are certain women
who become absolute monsters who are
honestly just as bad as Mariah Carey but
Mariah Carey is known by the entire
world not a specific corner of the
internet no so it's like it's exactly
what you're saying it's like
Teresa lives in a bubble where everybody
coddles Theresa even on her show even
fans Union like their her fans like I'm
sure on social media everyone in her
comments is like Teresa Teresa and she
walked out of her bubble to promote an
event inside of her bubble and she was
shocked that someone asked her a
question and it actually was not an
offensive question considering he
doesn't know anything about her other
than what they told him about her so he
said okay one of the other hosts had
been to jail so it's like you could have
actually had a really now it's Teresa
and open conversation I'm sure that's
what they were hoping they didn't know
the monster on the other end they didn't
know they were talking to an actual nut
job right like not a human being so to
me even though she was obviously being
rude I don't even know if that's like
the right way to describe her like she
is the most delusional person that she
expects everyone to like live in Theresa
land no but Jackie us coming up but we
live in America Jackie us coming up with
a word for it that's not rude is us
being a part of the bubble and a part of
the problem because in the real world
that is rude no no it's rude and it
comes off as rude but um
it stems from like her greater delusion
right and like her lack of honestly like
awareness of what's going on around her
at all times yeah so that was a wild
story it does not surprise me whatsoever
love that he told us what they couldn't
talk about and that's a normal question
and she was like why don't you talk
about how I'm a four-time best-selling
author and it's like I didn't book that
you wrote I did because I just asked you
about your book that's what I was
talking about that's what everybody's
asking her about and if I hear the
phrase Namaste [ __ ] podcast again
like I'm not okay
Claudia you should listen to Namaste
[ __ ] podcast so that you could learn
how to be a little more Namaste
um
giving live laugh love she talks in like
Housewives quotes where it's like we
need to focus on the positive not the
negative from the nastiest [ __ ] ever no
it's so true like she's literally the
Hunchback who can't see her own hunch
and it used to be funny and now it's
actually infuriating you asked me a
question I'm not gonna answer it but I'm
gonna reply with be positive no and the
way like her her whole aesthetic but
specifically with the podcast being
titled Namaste I can't even say it I
can't even say it is so chewy like it's
so live laugh love it's so Millennial
like it's horrifying
those are my thoughts on Teresa today
but I think if you want to learn to be a
little more Namaste you should listen to
Teresa who is the epitome of Namaste
definitely check it out
um
and that's our show our final show of
the week so Jackie I wish you a
wonderful weekend I'm sure I'll talk to
you good luck in Delaware what did you
Delaware
why
that's a riddle
what did I just made it up
um so thank you guys for an amazing week
of shows here at the toast hope you
enjoyed all of them make sure to check
out the patreon this weekend if you're
looking for Content that's patreon.com
toast I'll see you all tonight in
Delaware and we'll be back in studio Jax
will be here on Monday so don't forget
to tune in for that I hope you guys have
an amazing day thank you so much for
listening to the toast the Millennium
Claudia do you want to know what Della
wore what her New Jersey
oh God thank you so much for listening
to the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know everybody through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast and
we're podcasting we found out Spotify
iTunes touch your public video I got rid
of guest box all the places maybe listen
to podcasts find us the toaster leave a
five-star review about how
we talented we are have an amazing
weekend we'll see you guys on Monday
bye